what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the pregame
before I start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and ring that
notification Bell the way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos like
the video on your way and um let's get
started so first and foremost guys do
you want to be the ultimate alpha male
do you want women to come up to you left
and right and just talk to you strike up
a conversation Chit Chat you're like
aren't you tired of approaching women
wouldn't it be better if they approached
you get yourself a women shouldn't vote
t-shirt today all of the women are going
to come up to you and say that's an
amazing shirt where do I get one so the
link to that is in the description it's
at the audacity Network dot store that's
the audacity Network dot store okay a
couple other announcements before we
start the show I'm the first guys super
chats are going to be read tonight
um please please don't give me anything
that is too too awkward okay look it I
I'm all for roasting you can roast me
you can roast everyone a little bit
we're all with it but like please just
be nice all right I'm gonna read it
still no offense guys I'll read whatever
but
um but you do have to pay the price
which tonight is what king over how many
dollars I'm 25 all right 25 I'll read
whatever you say but please nothing too
weird all right um two clubs channels
just pearly clips and pearl daily make
sure you go subscribe to both
um there's four membership tiers the
first tier you get to be a part of the
chat tonight
um second tier is Discord and our
members only videos we do have a lot of
members only videos so uh make sure you
sign up for those
um third tier you get to connect with me
on social media and fourth tier you get
a one-on-one call with me once a month I
really am goaded when it comes to
YouTube look it I just got this new
Talent like 10 000 Subs in a month some
of that that took some of you years I do
that in like a couple weeks right so
make sure oh go subscribe to Christine's
channel that was the lovely lady that
hosted the show yesterday
um you know I was feeling under the
weather so she stepped up so make sure
you guys go subscribe to her Channel and
also guys
um yeah make sure oh we're also signing
um YouTube talents in London so if
you're interested we're probably gonna
sign people in the next two weeks so
it's just pearly things one on my
Instagram please do not Pitch me the
same haul show I already I already host
it's like you're like can I do the same
thing you do that's like kind of
you know what I mean it's like they're
like a show about relationships like I
mean maybe it has to be original new
what's your take what's your commentary
yeah so pitch it if you're in London um
and how many likes to open up the chat
tonight a thousand likes okay a thousand
likes and we will open up the chat
tonight otherwise you have to be a part
of our first year of memberships which
is five dollars a month please sign up
for that and help support the channel
support any upgrades we want to build a
U.S office so if you guys you know it
all it all goes to supporting that so
thank you guys um for bearing with me
um through all the announcements
um but why don't we start um everybody
say your name your age relationship
status and a fun fact about yourself
starting here and then go around uh I am
Daisy I'm 24 years old
um I'm currently single and fun fact
um I actually went to UNI and studied
dance for three years oh wow so yeah
my name is Alessandra ceballos
I am 33 years old I am the wife of eyes
white and I had two more cancer brain
cancer
so I do my heel exercise
to keep very healthy okay
so you guys you you're married yeah oh
that's awesome it's been a while since
we've had a couple on the show go ahead
hey uh I'm ice white
um 43 years old
um and what were the other things name
age relationship status married yeah
because we already established that so
there we go
um and fun fact I actually got a really
weird dark one which was such a crazy
coincidence and it's related to London
um last year I think I was watching a
documentary on Netflix
um it was about Jimmy Savile and I
watched part two
and some something like 20 or 30 minutes
in
I saw a clip of the of like police
officers storming the residents like the
block my house was at uh that I was
living at a few years ago and I when I
was watching that I was like oh my God
that is so crazy I I almost had a heart
attack it was just so shocking that out
of all the buildings in the entire city
in the entire world they pick a clip
from the entrance I would go to to go to
my house and then they would they would
gradually show these upper Clips like
where they were going to I'm like oh my
God which direction are they going to
left or right and they went the other
way
um so it's just scary that someone there
was obviously a very bad criminal but
when that happened it was just such a
crazy but dark coincidence right so what
what was the what crime did they commit
um I I don't think I could see it but
um have you ever heard of Jimmy Savile
no uh so he he was like a BBC English
BBC presenter and like decades ago he's
dead now but there were allegations
coming out of things he was doing to
children so very bad okay okay
he catch me back in the building again
wait what what's your name dng dirty
dirty cat Okay is there something short
so if I say hey I have to say Hey dng
Dirty cash you can say whatever you want
like that you can see you know but it's
like a dng or dirty cash because dng is
my initials
Where I Come From what I do so and yeah
I'm 37
um I'm walking around earth like I don't
need nobody so obviously I'm single and
a fun fact about me is
um I love the quiz
you love to quiz yeah
okay like like general knowledge and all
that kind of stuff okay or I might just
sticking oh God so if we do the name
three countries thing you'll be able to
okay
um but today so today's topic is
actually
um is it over for single mothers so if a
woman is a single mother are they done
nasty and the reason I had this thought
was because of some stats I was sent by
them Dr David Baker very friend of the
show he's been on the channel he he did
um he's written a bunch of books one is
called the evolution of sex so he does
very smart guy and so he says 30 of
single mothers are divorced 55 of single
mothers never bothered getting married
in the first place so the majority of
single mothers never got married single
mothers are not desirable a 2023 data or
date psych survey of thousands of men
found 78 would reject a single mother on
dating apps so eighty percent of men one
kid you're done NADA
um it shows in wedding data single
mothers have a 17 chance of getting
married or remarried uh they've got a
slightly higher chance of getting a man
to live with them 22 percent
um and that's compared to a 50 to 60
chance of a woman remarrying if she got
divorced before she had kids where she's
basically single with a little bit of
paperwork meanwhile current divorce
stats for single marriages are 67 and a
third
meanwhile current I'm sorry meanwhile
current divorce rates for second
marriages are 67 and third marriage is
74 so even if you're one of the few
single mothers who manages to remarry
the odds are against it working out
so
uh what do you guys think is it over for
single mothers I mean it's a hard one to
be fair to be honest I mean I find it
hard I do only fans for a living that's
my job so um
I completely like you know sympathize
with single mothers because I get it
like not a lot of people want to date
and only fans girl like you know it's
it's a pretty you know controversial
career I suppose yeah
um you know I I don't know I don't see
why anyone wouldn't be desirable just
because they've got a kid like a person
I can you got to take care of the kids
yeah
I suppose I mean I like kids but I think
men like their kids I'm not gonna lie to
you I wouldn't want to date a guy with a
kid yeah
so you understand perfectly yeah I
suppose it's hard like I feel like uh I
don't know I feel like
I've met single mothers before and you
know sympathized with them and felt like
you know they deserve someone because
you know they've most of well I don't
know most of the single mothers I've met
they've been left by someone I mean I'm
not saying every single mothers oh no
they all leave they don't lie they're
leavers yes it's like 70 to 80 percent
leave yeah well I don't know like I mean
half of them didn't get married to begin
with so they kind of did it wrong to
start yeah I mean the thing is with me I
I sorry I don't want to go on but I'm a
very like I see things through Rose
tinted glasses if that makes sense so
with dating like especially I'll meet
someone I'll fall in love straight away
like I'm like that kind of girl so I
feel like divorce for me would never be
on the cards even like you know I have a
kid with someone I'd do it pretty quick
if I was like with someone like I would
have a kid like within like a year I
reckon which is pretty risky okay you
know okay so is it over for single
mothers
um no I don't think so if you're sexy if
you're hot you're fine you're living
life even with the numbers yeah the
majority it's over for why can't you be
a sexy single MILF like you could be a a
sexy single mother
you just stay single most of them right
yeah I mean wait wait because you
remember we have to go through these
numbers right you know
um 55 have never been married and eighty
percent of men are saying they would not
date a single mother so and then and
then so they only only 20 are gonna get
married so and then if they get married
um they have a 67 chance of getting
divorced
yeah so and if they're married for a
third time it's 74 percent
I would just say they're done I should I
I would just say you learn you tell the
younger women learn from me don't and
save for retirement that's what I tell
them just wrap it up yeah that's just
his protection like that's just then it
just solves all the issues isn't it well
I'm curious what do you guys think you
guys are married you you said um is it
over for uh single mothers well did it
even begin
so there's that so uh obviously those
stats are
well they that makes sense those numbers
make sense I believe that I think that's
going to be pretty accurate aren't
relationships hard enough as they are
and once you add children into the
equation and and this is just children
in general not we we don't have a
specific number it could be one two
three four five or more it just makes it
the relationship more complicated not
only do you have to have a relationship
with the woman you need a relationship
with each individual child too if she
lets you and you if you are a man who
would consider getting into a
relationship like that maybe you don't
know what these kids are like how you
would be as a father because you're
picking up where either nobody left off
or where someone else left off yeah
so what what about you what do you think
in your case we met three months
and after that we wanted to have a baby
okay even though it goes occur we fell
in love and I chose him because for me
is a good example for my daughter
because he doesn't drink he doesn't
smoke for me this is our uh he he
doesn't believe in God because I am
Catholic but but he has good things
because I always get in love of other
people who smoke other things so for me
he was the the correct person after
three months we say we are going to get
married we are going to have a baby
what's up with us everything is fine but
other people maybe what age you are you
are going to be a mother maybe 16. where
are you from I I am from Peru Peru yes
so is Peru a bit more traditional yes so
divorce statistics what was the
percentage you said like 68 yeah not
good it's a second marriage is 67 God
damn so Peru her country we got married
in Peru Peru is one of the best
countries to be married in and get
married in top five you know do you want
to guess what the divorce rate is no I
don't I don't know what it is
0.02
wow why I don't know it's Catholic but I
I guess that helps but I'm an atheist I
don't know that much about
um
how it is there but I think the one of
the great reasons that it could be so
low is because
when I went there for the first time for
example
they take family really seriously really
seriously cousins and like oh my God how
many ants does she have and uncles or
like 200 I I have a very tiny fragmented
family so it was just like I still don't
even know their names there were just
too many
um but that's the thing it's also
traditional it's Catholic because it's
Spanish uh colonized it so I think those
are the reasons for it
so did you guys meet in Peru no no no uh
we met in Camden in London oh okay I'm
curious did you find it like easier
dating here than in Peru yes we go here
I only download Tinder are you making we
is the he was very nice that day
everything
we we if they were we were together the
second day
in Peru not like this no no so so I'm
more I was asking like
would you say in Peru like are the women
thinner more feminine we're like here I
would guess they're probably fatter like
it's easier to get
it's easier to get like a better like
guy I'd met like you know like the pat
like I just imagine a girl from another
country comes to the West I don't know
much about Peru and just like kills it
so so yeah from the Midwest I remember
when they were doing the the Vikings
game in London a few months ago maybe
yeah and all these guys from Minnesota
or women too oh my God they're huge oh
yeah oh my God they're huge they were in
the London Underground and of course you
could pick them out because well they're
large but they were also were in the
Vikings colors and everything
um what a difference but I think what
she said to me before about Peru is like
when they when women get married they
start to put weight on that's kind of
natural anywhere but I think that's kind
of especially true and Peru but
generally people are pretty thin yeah
people live with a family is not like
here that you go out from school and
then you live alone no yeah no in Peru
you live with a with a parent maybe 40
50 did you get married
but here is different here you in Peru
you have to ask permission to the
parents to go out you have to arrive at
12 maybe one two yeah but you have to
always ask permission to the parents but
here in Peru is a saying people who are
very
[Music]
um
I don't know how to say uh
who doesn't care the the parents they do
whatever they want
[Music]
so what do you think is it over for
single mothers
pretty much
like in a nutshell pretty much because I
mean at the end of the day it's just for
a single woo for any man to get with a
single mother like it's just taking up
responsibility on both sides you know
I'm saying
is there an upside in dating a single
mother
um yeah when she puts the kids to bed
have you ever dated a single mother
I think I have in the pasture and when
you were dating them were you taking
them seriously
no I was I wasn't even that in that kind
of state of mind yeah thinking about
taking them that's what I I find is the
guys that say that kind of stuff aren't
really in a place for like dating
long-term typically sometimes the
exceptional single mother will slip
through but I think the problem that us
women do as we talk about the exceptions
and we sell a dream when most of us most
of the single moms it's over and done
with
yeah yeah yeah play it out I mean so
um on top of that I I wanna I wanna talk
about
I want to talk about body count what do
you guys no I'm not going to ask anybody
I'm not gonna I won't do you like that
so so so what
what do you think the average body count
is so the average bride is 31 in the UK
how many women when how sorry how many
men has the average woman slept with by
31. now this isn't asking you personally
this is just from what you know the
women you know 31 years old how many
that's hard because I know girls that
have slept with like hundreds of guys
like hundreds are they all on only fans
no not all of them you know like you
know I don't know but then I know girls
who they are with a guy and that's the
only guy they've slept with so it's hard
like I mean I'm not saying I've slept
with hundreds of guys
um but I would say probably around the
30 40 mark 30 40. yeah I reckon 31 year
old I reckon 30 40 men
yeah yeah I'd say that's that's about
right what do you think in Peru is that
normal 30 40 men yeah tell me tell me in
Peru and then your guests here for
example in Peru you are with a boyfriend
for five years
wow yes and then you cry you want to
kill yourself
so ratio so the women when do the women
start having sex or having a boyfriend
typically
[Music]
um
20 can be 13 in any age okay but in my
case was 19 19. and then typically
they'll date the guy for like five years
and I cry
but that's like normal right yeah
okay so how many how many guys has the
average Peru chick slept with typically
is
not everybody is the same
I don't know how to say they maybe they
don't have a relationship too no yeah
but so like gas like 5 10 20 what's the
for me was this day three okay you'd say
three in Peru okay
whatever uh what about you what's your
guess
um I think well for for the West I think
it if you're gonna guess it really comes
down to the kind of people you hang out
with but I I guess maybe on average uh
seven eight nine
why are you laughing because my is so
high compared to everyone well I mean
yeah to be fair I mean you know a lot of
only fans check yeah right I mean I
can't imagine those are the prudes right
no yeah no we uh no no I only found yeah
you're not prude if you do any fans
that's for sure that's yeah I suppose
that's probably why it's so high yeah I
I think the new I'll tell you the data
actually I'm just curious what you guys
like say between maybe 15 20. yeah the
newer numbers that's like the newer I
told you I'm good at quizzes yeah
so all right but I wanna I wanna look at
the data of what the men have to say
like what do the men think is acceptable
in terms of Body Count
yeah yeah yeah okay so
if you are anywhere over and also thank
you to Dr David Baker for supplying me
these stats this man has a photographic
memory in any question he just
all right um if you are anywhere over
eight bodies over 50 percent of men
under 35 will reject you as a long-term
relationship prospect that includes
left-wing men when you exclude leftists
and just look at centrists and
conservatives alone that number drops to
five before fifty percent of men will
reject you for a leftist alone who
claimed to be open and enlightened their
body count cut off as 12 bodies before
half will not date you sixty percent of
men will reject 12 plus bodies seventy
percent of men will reject 20 plus
bodies again as long-term Prospect not
short-term relationship or cheeky F
eighty percent of men will reject 30
plus bodies 85 percent of men are at 40
plus bodies this will there will be
roughly 15 percent of men willing
willing to long-term date a woman
regardless of Body Count even at 60 plus
bodies of course we also know what men
say and what they will do and what
they'll settle for is different however
if a man under 35 says he's reject eight
bodies he probably low-key doesn't think
much of a of the with 20
bodies he's dating meaning he finds her
less attractive because of it meanwhile
I see um data psych May 2023 has
um provided a breakthrough average and
Body Count unlike most surveys which
exclude outliers AKA with a
nervous uh with with enormous body
counts he provides the following woman's
average body count in 2023 without
outliers okay so this is without the
only fans ticks they take those out
um
is 19.
um women's average body count in 2023
oh wait sorry sorry women's average body
count in 2023 with outliers included is
19 women's average body count in 2023
with outliers excluded as 10. it's only
the median um that is seven already
higher than the usual five which is
provided in surveys a survey
median
um a survey median is the number that is
bang in the middle of responses with
half of women saying seven or lower in
the other other half saying seven or
higher and in some cases a lot higher
given that the average is 19. meanwhile
19 is at least closer to what we suspect
women's actual body count is at the end
of the day
um it's dishonest to exclude the horrors
because they result in a number that
makes women look bad are modern
women if someone asks who the average
body count of modern women and you say
five or ten you're a liar are
modern women too the average is 19.
damn so but so so one average we got
without the you know only fans models no
fans servers hookers whatever is 19 the
other one is ten
um so men are disqualifying women after
eight
what does that say for the future of
marriage and relationships
um well obviously in my industry I mean
obviously I do only fans for a living
um you know it it does and I know that a
lot of girls my age do do only fans now
it's a bit it's a bigger thing now so
there's more only fans workers than
teachers now really is that an actual
statistic yes oh my God I didn't know
that yes
well I you know it is a
um I said you know it you see the
lifestyle of only fans models and you
think like why can't I have that for
myself like you know I know there is
some things that are you know people
don't agree with that kind of thing
um but I don't know like an average only
fans model makes like 500 bucks a month
it's not no I know
um I definitely make more than that
no I I get that you know I I have heard
that statistic before yeah you know I I
do get that you know but I think that's
because a lot of people on any fans
don't know how to Market themselves
properly
um I don't want to keep like go on about
it but it's hard to take to Market your
naked body yeah I know well no but a lot
of people don't be like the easiest
sound I know but I feel like there's a
lot of people that that market it like
so wrong like they just don't like you
know like I feel like yeah you know it's
a naked body like you either you either
like it or you hate it kind of thing
like but there's a lot of people with
like you know you have to have a niche
with only fans like you have to know
what kind of like okay what's your Niche
so that's true I'm letting you all into
a little secret you have to subscribe
everyone listening to me they will no
guys we don't we don't fund simping no
do not subscribe I'm tired of you
funding degeneracy but please keep going
what's your name at The Little Princess
by the way no no no guys guys look at me
we're not sipping today
so I I don't know like I feel like I
figured out like quite early on that
people thought I was a lot younger than
what I was
um so obviously I'm 24 but I I I I used
to have brown hair when I had brown hair
I looked a lot younger
um a lot of people were like God you
look like you're like 15 and as creepy
as that is guys like you know people
like that stuff like they like to think
they're speaking to someone who's still
in school
oh so your your Niche was school girl
yeah that kind of thing like if you have
like an agency or is it
um no so I completely manage myself
um I have worked with agencies before
um like early on so I've only done any
fun since January this year so I've
literally only been doing it for like
what seven eight months nine months
um I worked with an agency for a few
months uh but they really didn't do me
any good so I left them and I thought
you know what like I'm giving them
part of my earnings it's like that I'm
going to do it myself yeah now I just
yeah I I mean obviously it's a lot of
work and I treat it like a full-time job
I think that's what a lot of any fans
girls don't
do and that's why they only get 500
pound a month is because they don't
treat they think it's like an easy way
out do you know what I mean well I mean
it's easier than like working at
McDonald's
like don't you have to go a little bit
extra to get that little bit more I mean
yeah I'm
like that means you have to play an x
dot extra
what do you mean like what you mean so
you've got you
you're competing okay
I made maybe we'll play it I made a
hierarchy of whoredom
could you pull up that video I just
think it'd be trying to show them but
not we'll get to it and um I guess like
and I had some only fans models here
okay and I guess they they judge each
other well sort of they won't say it but
they kind of say it or they feel like
based on what you do there's like better
and worse where oh she's the real
and I'm not a real pee well I mean I
think it's like uh the big fat hole wow
I mean because I wanted to Define you
know who's the horizon
well yeah anyways so how far do you go
in terms of
it depends on how much money people
offer like I mean I'll do anything in
reason anything to do with like poo or
we I won't do like I can't that's do you
like sleep with people on camera no but
I I do girl girl on camera oh okay how
do you have some boy girl stuff
but um I don't do it very often why do
you cringe at that though if you do
because I feel like boy girl for me
right is a very
um sounds bad because this is completely
contradicting like what I do for a
living but I find with boy girl like for
me it's a very intimate experience like
having sex with someone like you know
it's it's like something I want to keep
close to my chest you know what I'm
saying like it's like to a certain
degree yeah I I don't know like I
suppose if it was with someone I didn't
care about and I didn't love then maybe
it wouldn't be as because like are you
are you really maximizing your profit
do you know what I'm saying because
you're competing with other girls that
are really going the full month or going
the full way yeah no I know exactly what
you're saying and I probably could do a
lot more boy girl stuff but I do find
that a lot of my solo stuff does do well
and I do a lot of custom stuff on there
so like I'm saying you might be missing
your niche
guys that probably are fantasizing and
wanting to see you in that way but
you're not giving it so oh okay I have a
question I have a question so I I have
um Pearl's World Okay and like and like
this is I just have these phrases of
like if Pearl was in shot I'm not in
charge so I have no say right but this
is just in Pearl's world the laws that I
would pass so one of them is that women
shouldn't vote
now now I know we're not here to talk
about that today but rule number two is
I would ban only fans really so yeah so
if Pearl got in charge today and I
banned only fans what would be like your
game plan
um well
I would ban it all I'd like and I would
like prosecute you guys to like the
fullest extent do you hate only fans
yeah I do I think it's bad yeah
two well you seem like a nice lady but I
just I don't like the whole thing yeah I
get it I I just think it's like you know
bad for society I get it I get it I mean
you know I I completely get why people
feel like only fans is bad um I just I
feel like I've figured out and I'm like
you know what this is oh it's easy money
right yeah yeah yeah yeah and and do you
know what there's people on there as
well that are actually quite interesting
people like I meet guys on there and I'm
like oh you're actually cool ride what
kind of guys do you meet oh well there's
lots of guys I mean I mean do you know
what there's a whole week big wide range
of guys on there like you get like young
guys like 19 18 year olds and then you
get guys in like their 60s 70s like
older old old guys
um are they are they usually awkward no
I mean I mean some of them are some of
them don't really know how to speak to
women I mean I guess a lot of people
that subscribe you know maybe
I don't know I feel like it's hard
because a lot of people are lonely these
days a lot of people don't get out it
sounds so bad but you know what I'm
saying like and I just I just provide a
service I suppose oh um Thane mattra has
a message for you I don't know I paid a
hundred dollars to say this I'm gonna
read it it's all fun and games until
later in life when you look at suicide
rate mental disorder and qualities of
Life retired corn
ecam models
yeah I I know yeah I do get that um I
understand that you know
a lot of girls who have done this kind
of thing you know that you know you've
got to think about the future when you
have kids when you have a family like
when you have a husband so I'm curious
do you think you'll be different like if
we see all the like corn workers the
e-workers kind of go down this path
where like they do this they usually go
broke and die alone do you I mean I'm
just being honest you know what I mean
like like Mia Khalifa like let's look at
yeah you know she did get I'm not saying
no one like but like then she gets
divorced and then yeah now she's kind of
you know do you see yourself like do you
see it being different for you yeah if
I'm honest
um I have got a plan at the moment
um I don't want to go on about it too
much but I I I'm not gonna lie I'm a
Serial spender uh I see something I like
and I'll spend the money I'm like so
this sounds exactly the same
exactly the same
yeah I mean that's um but I am a Serial
spender but I feel like I've really
realized like how important money is for
my future like I did obviously I went to
UNI I did dance it didn't really work
out for me I auditioned in in London in
the West End that kind of thing
um obviously it's not really what I can
do now because of my career but um I
just I just think that I've really the
last few months especially realized how
important money is and I've started you
know saving and that kind of thing and
um I think by the time next year comes
around I'll be in a good position to
maybe invest in something bigger and
then that means that I don't have to do
anything such as what invest in what
um I would really like to start my own
agency
um in dance in like in like Ibiza or
like somewhere like that or like
Marbella like I spoke to you earlier
about like I like going to my beer quite
a lot and but I think the club scene for
dancers is really big but I I go to a
lot of clubs
um in Marbella who do they teach to
dance typically
what in the clubs no like you said dance
like oh you would be like adults yeah
yeah like like
um so adult dancers in clubs if that
makes sense okay okay but a lot of the
dancers like abroad in like you know
Ibiza and things like that I watch and
I'm like for real like oh that sounds
really big-headed but like I'm just
saying like that they could be a lot
better so I think it could be something
like like that or I mean obviously the
property game is massive at the minute
so that would be another thing that
maybe I would get into but um I don't
know I haven't really thought about it
too much but I do think that this sounds
like the same path no don't oh my God
I'm not no no don't don't commit don't
do that
[Music]
saying because it's like you almost
throw away like you know it doesn't
sound like you're a pretty girl you
could have married rich that's what I
would have did like I said no you can't
that's gone no the richest men don't
want only fans no offense yeah I mean
you have to know that right yeah no I
get that I mean I suppose I don't know I
I don't know I I just I've had I've been
so unlucky with love like ridiculously
unlucky and I I think I got my heart
broken last year and I was like you know
what bugger it she's doing only friends
when you was in the relationship no no
no so you broke up and then like you did
only yeah yeah yeah what was that like
the the knock-on effect of the
relationship I suppose like it really
affected me the blast my last breakup so
my last breakup was around a year ago
um and he really broke my heart like
I've never had my heart broken before
but that really broke my heart and um I
suppose like I saw the lifestyle that a
lot of the girls were living who did
only fans and it made me think do you
know what like what am I actually I
worked for a wine company before I did
only Vans and I literally worked in an
office and I hated I hated it I don't
think I could ever go back to a nine to
five now ever in my life that's what I
was the only fans girls so yeah they do
exactly it's making money lifestyle but
they're being liberating though yeah
yeah and I enjoy it I really genuinely
enjoy it like I know so you don't think
it's like a chore to happen no no and I
I think it's interesting to meet people
I know people will be like what the hell
like you know these guys are paying to
talk to you A lot of them are perverted
as well so it's not like they're giving
you their true genuine selves you know
what I'm saying they're looking at you
from a sexual standpoint but I don't
know I suppose I'd I just think that
what do you think of the people who
subscribe to you
I'm money are you rich no
um I suppose I think
um
I think it depends on how respectful
they are
um I'm a very I'm an empathetic person I
mean I'm a Leo I don't know if you guys
are star sign people but I am a star
sign person and I am really obsessed
with attention
um I love it when people give me
attention and make me feel like I'm you
know wanted and a lot of my past
relationships have made me feel like I'm
unwanted if that makes sense I think
that's most women though yeah yeah yeah
I mean I get that most women do feel
like that but I feel like it maybe gives
me a little bit of that validation that
I so but yeah but then you're gonna go
crazy at like 35 because you know your
looks are gonna go like you're pretty
now right but 10 15 years you're going
to be significantly Less Pretty yes
that's why you have botox oh no no then
then they just start to have these like
frozen foreheads
yeah yeah I know I know so in 10 years
your skin is going to be so thin your
face is gonna be like froze it's gonna
look really weird I've seen what I've I
see the the only fans models of tomorrow
they come on the show so I see I've met
you in 10 years
what I'm saying just keep it yeah look
after yourself go to the gym and eat
clean and you'll be good yeah yeah yeah
no no but I'm saying you you won't get
to say it's delusional to think you'll
get the same attention in 10 years no
you won't no I mean you can try and
preserve it as much as possible you
could try but it doesn't work now come
on let's just live in
saving money yeah yeah only fans isn't a
long term it's not it never is for
anyone like you know what I mean like no
the only reason I'm asking I'm just
wondering because it just seems like
when I talk to only it's not just you
it's me but I just I always just wonder
what the long-term plan is like if you
know it's gonna remove your dating
prospects and it always seems like
there's like a plan of like a business
but never like an actual one that
started again and it's you I've met you
in different bodies but at 32
28 at 37 and they all have the same plan
and maybe it's like I've heard the you
said dance and something else the
whatever else you property that they
they always say yeah they always say yes
you're better off investing your money
in some stocks and just let you know
what I'm saying and just just do it
of who she can because if you look from
the age of time people have been making
well I just I just wonder because I just
wonder because typically only fans
models like are usually pretty
attractive and so I'm like well I'm just
wondering like why are they never saying
no no no Jake no you are you're very
pretty but I always wonder I'm like why
do they never think to like marry a guy
like they always want the lifestyle and
I'm like you could get it through
marriage I mean yeah but why don't you
just learn to trade or something like
like trading is just as people make just
as much money you can't learn that like
are you yeah
this is the thing if you're gonna tell
yourself that you can't expect the
husband no okay I've just I'm too dumb
you can't tell yourself you're too dumb
I'm just being honest women don't learn
those type of things like we could talk
about exceptions but I'm talking about
the rule we don't do it and they don't
really they don't really want what they
say they want out of life because a lot
of things is dedication and focus and
you know okay yeah but I'm just I gotta
I gotta act on I gotta act on average
this is true or that's something women
aren't gonna they're not gonna learn
these women is average I don't want I
don't know I'm just saying like marrying
Rich that that could have you get I was
like you could get like a job at like a
ball you know because you know being a
certain level of pretty you're gonna
have opportunities average chicks would
never have yeah you know yeah like why
not go to that Rob I'm just curious well
yeah I mean obviously you know marrying
a rich guy you know I mean not every
girl wants to do that but I definitely
you know
I do think that that would be a lovely
lifestyle like you know being like a
Beverly Hills wife
driving around in a Bentley like that's
the kind of life I want for myself I
like luxury stuff I like I like the idea
of a luxury lifestyle like I'm not gonna
lie
um I suppose only fans glamorizes the
idea that you can do that for yourself
um and that's sort of what made me want
to do it even if the women make money
they just spend it like you're saying
and they just lose it like it doesn't
even become easy oh it'll go and then
they hit like 35 I'm just telling you
your future
yeah I mean King am I lying this is what
they hit like 35 their businesses fail
and then they die the moment I hear any
woman say she's going to invest in
property I just laugh because
because property game the property game
is one of the hardest games together and
make money so I'm saying you're saying
you don't know and you're saying you
can't trade if you ever sat down and
looked at a chart and just analyzed it
like you'll see what it does and it's
not harder too you don't need no Maps
you don't need to it's not it's nothing
that your brain intuitively can't
understand and and it's I think it's
much more liberating than taking your
clothes off
so let's say you're getting 500 bucks
per month from only fans let's be smart
about the generation of the money here
no she does well don't don't insult her
income
but if we're going to be practical what
we could do with this uh revenue is you
could take at least one hundred dollars
of it per month put that on etaro or
something like that some investment
platform
um make sure you diversify it don't pick
the stocks you like oh you're like Tesla
well that is a good stock but don't pick
the the ones because you like the names
you need to diversify so every month at
least a hundred bucks maybe you could
split into like 25 or 50 so you pick a
different one every single month and
then take another at least 100 bucks put
that into your pension and strategize
like percentages or specific numbers out
of that and what you're going to put
that in in terms of your future and uh
another question for you to do income
that you can do like you can go to sleep
knowing that your your money is gonna
work for you just so I'm saying and it's
not it's nothing that is going to have
anybody looking at you in any kind of
way but Smalls you see what I'm saying
yeah completely I get that I mean if I'm
honest I mean obviously I've only been
doing any fun since January and I think
when I started to make a bit more money
like the last three months I think it's
sort of it's a bit of a novelty it's
like oh my god I've got money like you
know I can buy nice things I can do nice
things I can go on holiday I can go to
Dubai which I've done two weeks ago
which I would never have been able to do
a year ago like and I think that's the
thing like I think you have to realize
when the novelty needs to stop and you
need to be like right okay I've got this
money now and I'm it's not gonna last
forever so I need to do something with
it
um it's not that the money's not gonna
last forever the candle's burning in all
kinds of forms so uh only fans was
banned at one point and then it came
back again maybe I could ban it someday
exactly
I would send you guys to the streets I'd
be like yeah yup and I'd be like women's
shelters nope don't do work on the red
line imagine doing that to Miami oh my
God that would be like an apocalypse
yeah that would I would send the cops
after them I would be like get get them
anyone that tries to do it why don't you
like it
um because I think that it's turns women
that would have been wives into
and check this now who's educating
Society if there's more only funds women
than teachers yeah I would get rid of
voted there's a lot of stuff I even I'd
even get probably get rid of women's
sports and I was a part of that you know
there's a lot of stuff I just think is
probably bad I mean the football isn't
the same I mean it's just they just keep
whining about pay I'm like get rid of it
do you guys blame the girls for any fans
or do you blame the guys like the guys
who subscribe
the guys have to subscribe to something
don't they so yeah but they have needs
you know I mean but they couldn't get
needs anywhere else I mean they can go
to Soho but why don't they go to Pornhub
why do they come to it they probably do
after they've come to YouTube
this is a whiteboard moment he's gonna
get it I'll explain what's going on okay
I'm ready I'm so ready there is um
there's also another 100 super chatty
wants me to read thank you Thane we
missed you most women cannot qualify or
even handle being married to a rich
person watch the NBA wives sit front row
knowing that the Mistresses are in the
bleachers or at the hotel do you think
do you think you could be married to a
rich man and know he has a mistress or
two nice that are better looking than
you no because you know you'd get
pregnant you'd have the kids and then
there would be the mistress I couldn't
be with a guy knowing that he's sleeping
with someone else really yeah but I mean
if it was like you're an only fan I mean
yeah isn't that a little yeah but I
suppose yeah no no you are right you are
right but I I don't know like I mean if
it was like an old guy with like
wrinkles and stuff I feel like maybe
yeah like I wouldn't mind if we had a
few girls like if he was you know paying
my rent and paying for my car and stuff
paying for me to drive a Bentley yeah
like but if if I don't know it's a
difficult one I think like
guys
guys are a funny species sorry guys I
don't want you to get offended by this
but you know like I don't know
okay I'm ready
the Whiteboard
okay
so what we got going on I'm gonna
you know what
I guess
so what do you think the point of
society is like what do you think is the
point of all of us being here
I mean if I'm honest
um
I think we're all part of the Matrix
I think we're all living and there's
Society there's controlled by by the
government
um but I think the point of society is
that we're all being controlled and that
we need to you know what should be the
point like if we weren't controlled like
what would be good
um I think the point of society should
be that we should be living to be happy
and enjoy our lives and live our lives
to the most reproduce reproduce yeah
fulfillment like I think it's uh comes
comes down to farming so uh whatever the
word was like cultivation thousands of
reproduction and cultivation what do
they call it in in history when farming
was invented what's what's the word I
can't remember but
um since then Society has existed so
some people would do the farming people
would do other things that is where
Society comes from so because of that we
get food more easily
there's uh using cattle there's uh
getting plants and like fruit and
like that
um so it just makes it easier instead of
hunting every few hours
so now it gets to the point where we
have technology all these other things
because we handled the food a long time
ago
but like what do you think the point of
society today it should be like in your
Ideal World
uh I I think it should be that you can
just have your family have your
relationships have your life handled as
simple as that okay good good that's I
would agree I would say family right I'd
say I would I would in Pearl's World
family is the most important thing yeah
yeah okay so this is what's going on in
the dating
so the problem is all of us women think
we're hotter than we are and we deserve
more than we don't do now did your ex
cheat on you is that what broke your
heart yeah of course okay because you're
shooting out of your league
it's not just you it's okay we've all
it's happened to pretty much every chick
I've just I've done so many of these
because
um so these are the the top guys
and dating app data and you know sexual
who sexually active data like a third
amenor virgins or haven't had sex in the
past year well tell us we're all
sleeping with the same men so here you
go he's sleeping
yup yeah it goes yeah yeah and so you
know he'll be like you're my girlfriend
you're my girlfriend you know but none
of them it's just yeah you're just we're
all side chicks so the what happens is
as a way to supplement this these guys
are like because sex is a need for men
there's there's studies that have said
sex is actually a need so it's like now
the women are all sleeping up what are
these guys supposed to do that's where
you guys come in you do guys you got the
only fans workers do offer a service but
you know I think if we got rid of some
of those like policies that are paying
us to just sleep with the same men and
incentivize families that would be
better and it would be like this it
would be like
boom boom and then we'd all have like
can't you you see but the problem is we
have Instagram so we just all think
we're amazing and look like our filters
so we're just like we live in this like
La La Land I don't know what it is it's
not you know it's everybody you know I'm
not even saying uh but yeah and that's
why ban only fans is because then
um these chicks could stop living off of
the money to be and they would go
find a guy yeah no we'd all have
families I do agree then life would be
good it'd be like Peru yeah
let's go to Peru no well or
or you could just ban I would ban birth
control really I'd ban abortion yeah we
just ban everything I might ban women's
sports it does the same thing
um
that's why you got so many lesbians in
the NBA it changes your hormones hand it
has yeah and I did it for like years so
um oh wow yeah I was I was thought I
almost went pro
what exactly did you do
um I played I actually I was like a
multi I did basketball volleyball ran
track played soccer I did everything
yeah but really what it does is it's a
lot of what they do is they do a lot of
subsidized industries that turn women
into man really and so it doesn't makes
you more masculine it changes your
hormones a lot of chicks become lesbians
and yeah and the truth of the matter is
nobody wants to watch it anyway
I'm not gonna I mean there are some good
there are some good things like I
learned to work hard like there's some
good skills I learned from it but I
think back and I'm just like honestly
it's kind of a useless skill now like
what do I you know I do think that male
like female females definitely have a
like a female role like that's how my
views on things like I do think that if
I was gonna be a wife I'd wanna be a
housewife like I don't know if oh yeah
because um you know you know what's so
funny you know it's so funny about that
every woman wants to be a house what
what do you think your day in the life
of a housewife looks like get up bye get
my kids ready for school drive them to
school in my nice big Range Rover drop
them off of school
there may be you know Bake Some Cake and
yeah let's clean the house do the
washing okay so what do you what do you
think a man has to make to afford a
housewife hmm
probably like
100 100 200k a yeah okay let's say let's
say let's just go with this okay just
wait uh make sure she wants a Range
Rover she's not just a normal house yeah
I'm definitely gonna be a Range Rover
mom no you will not
all right so 100K 100K so what percent
of guys do you think make 100K like
like between 10 to 20 percent
10 to 15 yeah you're right roughly right
I mean I don't remember these like ten
percent yeah five percent or something
like that I I know 100K here is higher
I'm thinking U.S terms but it's probably
like eight but okay close enough right
so what age do you think that men make
that much money oh between that and boy
I reckon 55 men's income Peaks sugar
daddy
so so you think a guy works to 55 to get
a housewife and in return
he wants her to go shopping in his Range
Rover and gets nothing in return because
I didn't hear anything you'd do for him
well he would he would get me as his
wife okay so you're telling me a guy
that worked he made it to 55 worked his
whole life busted like these men have
hard jobs they bust their ass to get
there okay most men aren't gonna make
that right yeah and in return
he he gets sex that he could get from
any oh and he gets a trophy wife
in it like he gets a wife that he can
say look my wife's sexy do you think do
you think beauty is rare
um no no okay so he gets a like
something that there's a new 18 year old
every day exactly or we could say 20 if
you think that's weird I don't care
whatever the new there's a new trophy
wife born
I don't know like I just think that um
the housewife lie
I've seen it I've seen it firsthand I've
seen women that are you know where where
do you know these women from
I don't know if I can out them because
no names no names
um like what I'm just how did you how do
you know him um well
I don't know like I've met people before
um who I don't want to say too much but
they
are married to very rich people who have
you know
I mean these are like the one percents
like you know like did you meet them
through sex work no no no
um I'm I actually met them in my last
relationship okay so if someone you like
knew through friends yeah yeah yeah yeah
and they were married to a rich guy yeah
yeah yeah okay
um and did you know I'm well yeah yeah
okay and she just did nothing yeah yeah
nothing yeah yeah just at home housewife
money like and you know I mean obviously
how many women did you know like this
um I mean not to that extent that was
only one okay so you met one yeah I mean
well yeah but that I'm gonna be that one
percent
no no this is what this is so delusion
no this is what I could do I could say
you will you will not no that's why I
was saying I was like you could have had
a shot maybe and you want them to be
faithful that wasn't getting
cheated on come on yeah oh come on they
all do like I know but like you've said
here yeah like like you know if Society
was different we would be able to just
meet a man reproduce only fans wasn't a
thing like yeah happy life you can still
do that oh that you know I mean it's the
choices and decisions you meet yeah but
do you not think with society today like
no you you that's not the way life goes
because you know it is because I feel
like we're in a following age if you're
not following on Facebook you're
following someone's ass or your foot
like we don't have to follow you can
lead the leaders breed leaders you
shouldn't be following anybody you
should want to stick out in society and
say well I want to make a difference
through doing this or maybe not
following what they call it is the norm
you know what I'm saying well you know
what I'm actually I'm actually glad you
said that because it actually shows
something about female nature we hate
feeling like we missed out we hate it we
can't stand it oh yeah this is this is
why we're kind of messed up today is
because we see we meet these women that
sell us a dream or like it's on
Instagram and we feel like if we get
married we're missing out and I think
it's a bad quality that most women
nowadays don't want to challenge
themselves like oh I'm lazy yeah and I
mean that's more of an endearing
character than taking off your clothes
and the thing the funny thing is though
um with like work ethic because I see
these women on Instagram they like the
soft life I call them the soft life
ladies they're like I just want to live
a song soft era yeah and be traditional
and the funny thing is I'm like you
realize our ancestors were farmers they
didn't they have none of these Trad
wives
like they they didn't live soft lives
they they helped their husband in the
fields they they were trekking carrying
water from miles and coming back to you
know
yeah like I'm like there was maybe like
in the 50s like a short era where women
were you know like the the guy went to
like more corporate in the U.S anyway
yeah but I mean those women still like a
lot of them worked part-time and a lot
of them still um I mean they had recipes
from scratch like they had traditional
qualities you know yeah the crazy thing
is
um the biggest mistake a lot of women
make when they think about being
Housewives is they think about the rich
Housewives but you see the rich
housewives are only a very small
percentage of housework it's crazy that
most women don't even see themselves
being Housewives unless the man makes
about 100K like she says and that's why
because to me
whenever I was asking a woman about
being a housewife that's what we usually
hear a Range Rover soft life you never
hear I'll be a housewife and I get on
the bus with my kids yeah well really
last one or I'll pull out the Hoover and
I'll you know what I'm saying the actual
Norm of a housewife a housewife has
nothing to do with luxury it has nothing
to do with domestication it has
everything to do with sacrificing to
raise a family yeah damn right
but I do think like I'm agreeing with
what you're saying I know do you think
that a housewife life must be a very
lonely life as well I can imagine it
being really low it doesn't have to be
if you don't want it it's not stopping
you from having friends I mean women
like to socialize and talk and do all
these other things so I mean it doesn't
stop I mean you get to you you get to
hang out with your kids exactly what's
that wifey are you lonely
yeah I am a lonely person oh no no not
you my wife Oh I thought you were
talking to me are you are you lonely
you know uh what I think is when you
have a baby you have to worry more
because the baby it depends on you know
if you want to do breastfeeding or if
you want to do both as the bottle that's
the milk so if you are going to do
breastfeeding you are you have to wake
up all day first yeah yeah you have to
clean the house like it depends how is
your life yeah do you have a soft fly do
you so you stay home with the kids yeah
is it a soft the soft life era in your
Range Rover and shopping no no no when I
go with her she wants to buy everything
she always cry you have to be very
patient it's a lot of things you have to
do when you you are a mother yeah I know
I get that like I and I do you know I
would love to be a mother one day but I
don't know it's I don't know I don't
know like I just I like my life now I
know like there is astigmatism between
only fans but I just like it like I
think it's fun like just I like that
every day it's different well I I think
you're actually right that's what's
happening is like we get these like fun
lives and we we get rich quick with only
fans right yeah yeah yeah yeah but I I
don't think that the world has really
told us what's gonna happen again at 35
roughly for women it's like the looks
start to go what's the long-term plan
because even even without
um like even let's just say I doubt it
women are just terrible with money but
you'll probably be broke but who knows
Tiffany will be yeah I know maybe he'll
be the succession and just business boss
chick okay let's just say I'll be the
next Jeff Bezos no you will not
[Laughter]
let's just let's just say you do it
right it's like you know now I mean your
kids would get bullied yeah no and don't
get me wrong I've already I've got a
little brother and you can only imagine
what that's been like yeah well I mean
he was when I first started only fancy
was 15 and you can imagine like boys 15
at high school what that was like for
him how did you deal with that
um and not very well I'm not gonna lie
because I'd never had to deal with
something like that I didn't really know
because my family and my everything
um hold on your brother was 15. yeah and
he was getting like backlash from what
you was doing yeah because his 15 year
old boy mates were seeing what I was
doing so 15 year olds are allowed to be
on only fans yeah yeah yeah that's crazy
yeah yeah so they were like would they
show them your pictures and stuff well
no I don't think any of them actually
subscribed but I know a lot of them you
know so or the link they saw you know I
do Post
um
not explicit content but I I see right
racy content on Tick Tock and Instagram
what I can without getting banned
um and you know people see that I mean
I've had to block my family from a lot
of my social media
um so I get a little confused because
like what you're saying doesn't match
how can your family be everything if
they have like consequences and you
don't like you care more about like your
lifestyle than your family yeah I
completely get that and that that you
know that does make sense
um completely but I think that my family
have always supported me and I I'm
always very honest with them and I I
mean I knew that it was going to be a
sacrifice and it was going to put a lot
of pressure and stress and you know
stuff on them but
I mean I went to them up front before I
even started any fans and I said look
this is what I'm gonna do
um you know if you're really not happy
with me doing it I won't do it um they
told you to do it yeah yeah
wait wait wait who who said to do it
first my mom I knew it it's always the
mom that's crazy
did your mom reap any of the benefits
from you do it well they I mean they
obviously you know I pay for things for
them now whereas before I was like can I
have money
um but I think they they like that I
have more Independence now I you know
before I started only fans I relied on a
lot of people you know and now I don't
rely on anyone do you know what you know
what societies lied to us is it like the
the answer would have been a husband
like that's what the answer is supposed
to be that's what I mean our society
doesn't tell us to our parents don't
even tell like I mean your mom telling
you to do only fans the craziness she
should have been telling you to get
married yeah but I think from previous
relationships oh my God sorry
um
um uh I um I think from
um past relationships it's made me like
feel like I'm maybe
won't find someone won't find a husband
well you definitely want now do you
think
now thanks guys I'm gonna see this in a
nice way so you said January you started
only then yeah this year so the way I'm
thinking about it is this is like a
block in in your timeline and this block
is the blockage that stops you getting
another relationship maybe if you didn't
do only fans I I'm not grilling you or
against you or anything
um maybe if you didn't a few months
later now or tomorrow or a few months
from now just a matter of patience you
could have had enough relationship maybe
way better than the one you had before
probably not way better because she was
probably shooting too high like we all
do you know what I mean so it probably
would have been like worse in your eyes
but but it could have been better you
know what I do believe it's evident
you're pretty you go you know I'm saying
like you could definitely find you a man
that would that would like take you on
for who you are and not what you do just
what I'm saying and don't don't stop
selling dreams your numbers are not in
your favor when men were surveyed on
dating only fans models it was like I
can't remember if it was 70 80 said they
would not do it no but I'm saying like I
wouldn't I wouldn't necessarily I
wouldn't necessarily I wouldn't
necessarily now go out there telling
guys does that that's what you do I
would put that to the side just what I'm
saying like you don't subcommit fraud
but don't you think everyone commits
fraud you know I mean like on a basis
like they don't tell people what they do
up front straight away just what I'm
saying don't you think the reason guys
don't date only fans models though is
because usually the model's earning more
than them and they don't like that not
necessarily you know no no no no no I
don't know I just feel like why would
you okay okay I'm gonna I'm gonna no men
do not care about your money I promise
to God they do really they don't give a
it's like nothing to them it's like
it's like when men talk about their shoe
collections it's like it's like it's
they don't care but the real question is
why do you think that the reason why men
wouldn't want an audience model has to
do with money rather than values if a
man wants to get married he's thinking
about having children that men think
about things we don't just jump into
things so if we're going to have
children we're going to think about the
repercussions of having a mother who has
done sex work that is on the internet
that people can have access to these are
the things men think about yeah it's
what qualities do you hold as a woman
you listen to the separate I think
everybody is the relationship that you
have is to teach you for example the
first one was in I met him in um in a
party the second one was in um stay work
the third one was in the University so
all all those is the persons teach me
something and then I met him and uh all
the situations you pass before you you
have to think I don't have to fell in
love of that person is not going to
happen that oh and you were looking for
a good person and then you can have a
good family I mean you're still young
yeah nothing worth having comes easy so
don't feel like you have to like every
time you get into something it's gonna
be that you know what I mean like you
have to test the water sometimes you
have to put your pinky toe in and if
it's not that then you off to the next
Lake you see what I'm saying like yeah
you don't you don't have to always feel
like everything's got to be so in the
modern immediate just what I'm saying
yeah yeah take time out for yourself to
learn yourself learn another person and
and then you can know whether you want
to integrate or go about your business
or do whatever it is in life we live in
an on-demand Society so you want food
right now you can use ubereats someone
will come to you on a bike with
your greasy McDonald's that has gone
cold if you wanna uh you could use Uber
to go somewhere uh there's there are
just so many things which are on demand
it's like um convenient straight
straight up convenience and it happens
because it's a product people pay for it
it's convenient uh we are relying on too
much convenience so when Society began
it began began because of food
becoming more accessible in a smarter
way farming
now
you can just get whatever you want now
there are shoes uh it's your basic needs
so when only fans really serves the male
human urge
for sex or jacking off yeah which kind
of fulfills half of their biological
need for that aspect food
serves you nutrition it's not just for
the basic stuff it's not just guys that
want like sex I mean I get a lot of guys
on there who just want company they just
want someone to talk to they're alone
yeah that's a basic human Dean too yeah
like yeah for real but like I feel like
ever get married guys oh yeah who
they're what yeah their wives aren't
doing anything I had a guy a few weeks
ago
um who messaged me on there and he said
that he walked past me with his wife and
his wife had a go at him because he
couldn't take his eyes off me and he
messaged me on any fans and he was like
yeah I was with my wife and I saw you
you know if you want to be that guy oh
dear I know it is I mean you do get a
lot you hear a lot I mean there's a and
it's but it's not just I think the thing
about only fans is that a lot of people
on there go on there for their
um specific fantasies if you want to
call it that CD fantasy CD fantasies
yeah like
um you know you get a lot of weird
requests on only fans like but depending
on the money you know
I mean I tip soup over my head for 500
pounds the other day but anyway is that
something that you would do though like
normally like no well no it's not an
everyday thing but like I mean I didn't
have to be naked the only friends that's
got you acting out a character for some
people I know but like why you're
telling me if someone offered you 500
pounds a tip of Tina soup over your head
you wouldn't no because I couldn't I
know I can get 500 pounds a lot easier
than doing something than that ah see I
just think like and that's kind of so
you're not going to be able to
consistently do that every single month
No One's Gonna Pay you every single
month to pour soup over your head that's
why you get new people to come and
and we have new requests I don't know
like I don't know I just think that only
fans yeah I get what you guys are saying
completely don't lower your value for
money like that's that's pretty much it
but money's everything it is but it's
how you go about it you know what I'm
saying I mean like you you don't want to
tarnish your whole being a reputation
just due to the fact you love money do
you know what I'm saying it's not that I
love money I'm definitely not like I
know you guys probably think differently
now but I'm not a materialistic person
like I don't but you did too much no I
do I do I do 100 chica you just said you
did it for a lifestyle no I know I know
I know I know that I know that but I'm
just saying like I think that money
creates Freedom right yeah yeah we all
agree on that yeah yeah okay so so the
concern is like even if you have a man
but not necessarily your point of view
even if you have a man and a man should
handle all the money you're you're still
kind of like where's my security in in
having my own money
maybe is does that represent you say
that again sorry so the the man should
handle the money so let's say you were
in a relationship right now and you're
not doing it only fans he makes the
money he provides you with a bit of
money because he generates enough that's
okay yeah that would work yeah yeah I
mean I I just I don't know like I think
if
I don't know I feel like maybe yeah I
could have married rich I could have met
a guy who you know earned good money
yeah
could you could you could you stop doing
only funds for a guy that earns just as
much money yeah I could if he was the
right guy if I fell in love with him
yeah like it would have been treated me
what about 35 000 a year
pounds you get it yeah a man with
potential I'm not I I think I I'm I'm I
know I don't I've not really come across
that way tonight but I am a true love
kind of girl if someone if someone
clicks with me it doesn't I don't care
how much they earn like if they sorry
someone has a question okay oh dear do
you realize you're not getting marital
attention
what does that mean like attention for a
minute you're getting the wrong kind of
attention yeah no I I do realize that
like and I know that maybe
guys don't want to date me for marriage
they want to date me because I'm a Noni
fans girl like yeah I get that but at
the end of the day like
right now maybe I'm not thinking about
my future maybe I only think about the
present maybe I don't actually I've not
actually thought about the future that
much
in the last realistic thing you've said
today
oh thank you so much
um no I'd but there's nothing wrong with
that like you just being honest about
that just I'm saying that's yeah I'm
sorry so at the same time you could
still make those changes yeah no I just
it's in you can obviously tell you've
got that that quality in you but it's
like bringing it out of you just what
I'm saying I just think the future
scares me like I don't want to be scared
oh it should it should only fans workers
have a terrible things I would be
terrified yeah let's talk about the
scary future so uh not to press buttons
here but my wife has brain cancer it's
very dangerous cancer is not ideal the
the future is scary for pretty much
everyone but if you're young and you
don't have cancer can of illness
you got the future until you get an
illness so if you're young and you're
complaining about things uh just to
anyone watching you have nothing to
complain about you have the
future you need to think about the
future and you don't have to marry a
rich man who is going to be 55 years old
by the time he gets Rich we get to think
about the potential that a man has
yeah no I completely I completely agree
with what you're saying why do a lot of
women just want to get with a rich guy
that don't you want to because it's an
easy life yeah but can't you get that
yeah but my thing is like can't you tell
a man with potential that is headed into
riches now most men won't be rich I'll
tell you I've looked up there not
necessarily rich but comfortable enough
to hold down the family don't you think
that well but the thing is most women
want a lifestyle they don't want a man
and they don't want a family and that's
that that's the truth of the matter is
we live we have very selfish
narcissistic women because we've all
been on social media since we're like 12
so we're just told we're amazing we
deserve this awesome lifestyle and it
really deludes us like the equivalent
would be a guy getting unlimited sex at
12 years old that kind of mess you up
right we all have gotten unlimited
attention from the time we were super
young because of Instagram we start to
think this stuff is real that's why
she's talking about the Range Rover she
met like a rich person one time and now
it's like you know and then it's not
just you I've done the hundreds of these
so it's like you know these girls you
know it's not even just only fans
workers it's like average chicks like
what you guys are in your early 30s you
guys are a little better because you had
you the women of that generation didn't
get social media as young but like we're
kind of all deluded we're crazy yeah
because again we we've just had this
extreme attention from a super young age
and it's made us insane don't you think
guys though like even she said she said
she did part of again doing only fans is
for attention oh yeah 100 validation
yeah that's the point where like we're
like hyper fixed on it like it's the
equivalent of a man like imagine men
having like a sex addiction like that's
the equivalent of you yeah and me I
completely agree I have an addiction to
feeling validated yeah like I completely
like you know I I it's a feeling I live
for it's really bad though like I mean I
I suffer quite badly with yeah anxiety
and I've suffered with with an eating
disorder as well like I mean I don't
want to go on about it but it's it's
because that I've constantly want
validation from people the reason I got
thin the reason I lost so much weight
was because
I thought that if I was skinnier I'd get
more validation off people and then I
actually realized that when I was
skinnier people thought I was
uglier do you know what I mean so I
think you know well it's fomo too it's
like women we just don't like to feel
like we're missing out so we feel like
if we don't marry the rich guy we're
like missing out because that was a
total realistic option for us it's not
it's not no I get you yeah but I'm gonna
Read Super chats for a second and then
we're gonna watch my hierarchy of
whoredom video okay so um all right see
Masterson uh women on only fans belong
on a sex offender registry what if
there's only a sex work register only
fans registers don't register to only
fans no no yeah the like of registry
where like women's oh my gosh a mat oh
this is Imagine okay
you women have a registry and men can
submit if they have like their nudes or
they have like crazy stories about them
and then like if a guy wants a wife he
goes to this registry looks her name is
Facebook groups oh yeah
that's actually a good idea because
women can actually do that to see if men
are offensive um violent offenders or
sex yeah yeah you know what I'm saying
to start that business
what do you mean we start the business
with with the registry and then I'll
just give up you like to spend in your
band with money you're not getting in on
this cash machine you're not getting in
okay um
see uh matherson women who don't fulfill
their duty to family should be treated
exactly 100 like men who don't draft in
Selective Service
oh interesting uh poppy Vegas women
cheat at a higher rate than men I've
noticed I've none a thousand zero
percent were faithful four out of five
men's wives have offered me sex now I'm
40 plus the adults of daughters of my
friends have offered me sex I've always
said no see Masterson women's right to
vote should be entirely dependent on
their duty to their family if she's not
only fans are divorced or aborting
children she loses the right to vote and
should be fine 250 000 or five years in
jail see Masterson yet she continues to
do it uh puffy Vegas Pearl your
whiteboarding is the best thing ever you
should put it on every show off of 90
free tow pie I don't mind women doing
only fans of it just means that I get
all the benefits of their body visually
without even being their man hahaha keep
posting women subscribe enter enter
black dragon um by the way the new age
of verification laws only fans will will
be banned uh full of we taught a Mike
who chases Harry Alpha Kenny Body
Enterprise black dragon
most modern women do not understand that
money isn't everything and it comes and
goes rather the money rather than get
money from multiple men one good man can
give you the word uh for the world for
the rest of your life beyond his
existence of full we taught
testosterone does uh something to the
brain where it makes you enjoy hard work
unfortunately women don't have enough
testosterone to enjoy working hard so so
them leaning learning trading is an
anomaly uh puffy Vegas high value men
will never take single mothers seriously
me and all my friends that are high
value are and know are are no way
there's no way in hell any woman
believing this is living in total
delusion okay
um
yeah let's play my hierarchy of whoredom
video please
yes
that's me right there I'm ready yeah
oh is someone that does it for attention
what up guys welcome to the dust pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to my
whiteboard videos today I am going to go
over the hierarchy of boredom before I
start don't forget to subscribe to the
channel and bring that notification Bell
that way you're gonna be notified of my
daily video so this last week I decided
that I wanted to know more about
hoes nice ladies and oh I forgot
ladies and wifey material so this week
we did a show where we really wanted to
define the terms because a lot of men
out there cannot Define what's a
what's a what's a whole lot of the
women it's like what is this and I'd
like to tell you guys in 2023 if we go
by a historical point of view 95 of
women would be however we are in
2023 so we got to adapt to the time so I
surveyed some men to see what they
thought the definition that we came up
with was a is someone that has sex
for money or does things for
money a is someone who does it for
sex and a hoe is someone that does it
for attention so we went through some
scenarios as a class a isn't only
fans worker a stripper a hooker or an
escort I think I spelled escort around
wrong but never mind that a is a
woman feeds on her boyfriend one
nightstands because what's she doing it
for next we have a hoe now this is a
girl ass picks on the gram okay or 15
plus bodies now okay guys there's been a
lot of dispute some guys are saying no
it's way less than that I I just asked
the people I just I just report the news
let me know if there's anything else we
should add to the top three but that's
what we got for now so then we have a
lady so a lady you can have roughly 5 to
14 bodies okay but she cannot have
gotten these through one night stands so
no one night stands you can only have
gotten the bodies you maybe you got
ghosted tooken out but you could still
be a lady you have five to fourteen
bodies now let's define a nice lady zero
to five bodies is a nice lady and wifey
is a virgin his wife material so now
that we have some definitions what I
wanted to do was I wanted to make a
hierarchy of whoredom now I'm just
repeating back to you what the markets
don't shoot the messenger okay ladies
all right so here we have the least
desirable here we have the most
desirable and most rare So what is going
to go on the least desirable level in
terms of sluttiness this is the
hierarchy of whoredom alright so at the
bottom we have hookers now there's many
names for these ladies hook cookers
escort escorts Street Walkers night
walkers but at the end of the day
they're selling for money we have porn
stars now because they're not just
straight selling sex they have less
Partners but porn stars are above
hookers only fans ladies you're not at
the bottom but you're not far from it
you're just above hookers porn stars
then only fans next we have strippers
now A Stripper can go on to live a
normal life because there's no maybe he
didn't sell sex for money I mean we all
know what goes on in the strip clubs but
maybe she just stripped so then now this
is the most disputed one I asked the men
what's worse would you rather take a
single mother or a woman with a high
body count now we all know that they're
single mothers with high body count like
we all know but I I said you have to
pick one and the men picked drum roll
please
high body count if you sleep with too
many people you are barely better than a
stripper now what number this is is very
disputed across the board
um I I've heard numbers like around 25
at switches they'd rather take a single
mom I've had some guys say 10 I've had
some guys say 30. I don't know when it
switches exactly for men but let's just
say somewhere between 15 to 30 they'll
take the kid over the bodies don't shoot
the messenger now remember if you have
both your lower but if you just have a
kid and not the body count you're
slightly above the horse but not by much
I mean hoes these are hoes baby
baby the hoes and the and
remember level of ladies our mid body
counts so again I've had some dispute
but what I've gotten is like five to
like 15 roughly men will take that over
the kid but it switches around there
then we have low body count which
nowadays is like under 10 under five
again please don't shoot the messenger
I'm just repeating back what I've been
told and at the top version this is the
hierarchy of whoredom from Lee
um let me know if there's anything I
forgot guys you know I love giving these
lessons to you don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and ring that yeah guys
make sure make sure you subscribe would
you guys think accurate agree disagree I
think you're on to something yeah
actually I got in condition for that
first white board oh please do if she
has had sex with multiple men at the
same time she goes to the top
do you mean the bottom well on the first
board oh no okay okay yeah so if she
does it at the same time then she's
okay exactly why
not
well yeah but some men like that so
that's some men's fantasy greasy fans
yeah with greasy wait so wait
what's worse okay a girl that slept with
two guys one time or a girl that's like
and that's it that's all I mean it's not
but like let's just hypothetically or a
girl that slept with 10 men
we're all in one go I don't know but the
first one is a huge red flag in the
first place so I don't think the second
one is necessarily a huge red flag but I
think the first one is so yeah I just
want to know because what's interesting
is I like to know when it switches so
like when I do a kid it switches around
15 bodies they're like all right give me
the kid you know there's something I
realized
um I think the reason why women a lot of
women don't know
don't know how to separate the
difference between men's sexual
fantasies and what men truly desire is
because a lot of women don't understand
the phenomenon of post not Clarity a lot
of women don't realize that there are
some things that men would do in the
moment that they would literally regret
and hit themselves for literally five
seconds after they've knotted
So when you say stuff like some men
would love to run a train yeah in the
moment some men would love to do that
but a lot of men would literally hate
themselves the moment that they're not
for doing that
exactly saying I guess the same goes
with murder like a lot of guys would
love to murder someone uh but after it
happens they have regrets
where would you put sugar babies that
was the one thing I forgot
I have actually been a sugar baby before
shocking oh my God where does a sugar
babies above only fans
I think maybe there's a kind of
so I'm imagining the sugar baby thing is
well I guess it depends because is it
just one person you're being a sugar
baby for or is it I think I think
normally it's more than one yeah yeah
it'll be a problem if it's one person
then it's not that different from a
relationship it's still not as good as a
relationship obviously
um but being in a relationship with a
man having a husband you are the sugar
baby because you're the wife but you
don't have that Sugar Baby connotation
you're just being looked after for and
taking care of the family yeah I think
sugar babies is like the same level as
only fans personally like I think it's
on the same level I my guy is there
slightly better than you guys because
there's no video evidence yeah yeah I
mean I mean it's one thing I'll I'll
tell you my theory and I want the men to
tell me my theory is okay the men if
there's less evidence the better now
they don't want any of it like it's all
horrible they just want virgin wives but
in 2023 it's like if there's evidence
that there that anybody can just show
you yeah like for the rest of your life
now my kids like at least they can like
pretend it didn't happen yeah I suppose
you don't have to tell anyone it's like
a secret no even if they know it's like
at least they can like like okay I could
just not think about this forever yeah
you know but but then it's like when
there's video evidence of you having sex
with another guy like it's not only not
only like did you do it there's also
evidence you did it yeah but who doesn't
have videos having sex with guys these
days you know what I mean I just said a
lot of people don't have it that's just
really yeah that's just you
well I you know you've got to think
about the the way how women that do sex
work think to the average woman just
what I'm saying yeah no completely I get
that I mean I but I I you know I have
been an average woman in an average
relationship before I do not mean I've
only just started doing any fans and I'm
24. well well and I think I do think
that if there's you know yeah I think if
I think if there's sex tapes out of a
chick that also brings her lower um of
course what if the guy is like filming
and you don't know what you said about
your little brother though I'm saying
it's a look on effect it's the same
thing your brother is just not okay how
are you not gonna know her for guys
filming well like if you're in doggy and
like he's filming you and like you you
just don't know you're just like living
yeah but then it makes you look bad
because you're like picking guys that
would film you without telling you which
I think that's probably my problem I
pick them type of guy well you probably
just shoot too high and they don't care
about you that's usually what happens is
we just go too high on the higher yeah
but then it's not just you though it's
like pretty much yeah like most guys if
they see that a woman doesn't have value
in herself he's not gonna value her
simple as that yeah 100 but then I feel
like and the guys that you are getting
attention from it's a superficial
it's nothing wrong Also let's not let's
let's not blame the guys though like you
really do attract what you are so like
you're saying you're picking the wrong
guys as if it's like the guy's fault no
it's not really the guy's fault the guys
are the guys there who they are so if
you are picking those guys then it's
something about you it's not really
about them
yeah but then I mean a lot of because
the way you freeze it it's almost to
seem as if you're innocent in all of
this and then you're just unlucky and
picking the wrong guys no yeah I mean I
wouldn't say I'm completely innocent I
mean you know I'm not perfect that's for
sure like I know that there's a lot of
things about me that maybe people don't
like or don't get on with but I mean I
don't know one question I've always
wanted to ask the only fans go yeah
seriously like you earn your money huh
yeah only fans if he was in a
relationship with a guy yeah would it be
cool for him to get a percentage of your
earnings
yeah 100 then you'd be cool with like
giving him whatever you well I don't
know how much you make a month but
giving him 500 pound a month for
whatever yeah yeah I've completely I
respect I respect that I I think that's
a respectful way of saying look I thank
you for letting me do this and letting
me live my life yeah 100. well okay what
about when Andrew Tate said that if he
had a woman and only fans that he would
keep all her money what do you think I
mean as long as he looks after me and
takes me on his private jet and drives
around there she goes
there she goes there she goes back to
the Jets
I mean if I was if I was going up Andrew
Tate I'd let him have all my earnings
and then he can just you know look after
me yeah what do you what do you think
about I'm curious that because now the
girls come back and say they're like
trafficked later
like what do you what do you think about
that as in the guy I think I was like do
you know what's going on with the Tate
case in Romania yeah yeah yeah like
where essentially like the girls are now
saying that they were like human traffic
I mean I I don't
I don't necessarily believe that
um I mean I was saying to Omar earlier I
love Andrew Jane I literally love him I
know a lot of people think that's
controversial but I just think he's
hilarious I think this guy sorry gone no
I was I was gonna say I think there
would be like a line of only fans models
I would love to come and see 100 I mean
don't get me wrong like I I mean these
girls I mean there's a lot of things
that we could probably get into but you
know these girls posting tick tocks in
his house and all that kind of thing I
just think you know this guy he doesn't
need to traffic girls like he's living
his best life like what like what like
he's definitely not done that I just
think that you know he has too much
reach in the internet basically he does
I mean so people like that have so
certain amount of influence not just
over the internet but the world or
something like someone's gonna hit on
you you know what I mean and they're
gonna build in a generation Because He
Lives such a a luxurious lifestyle and
he's seen as a a b magnet to a certain
extent they're going to use women
against him oh yeah for real and he's
got such an influence on young men these
in our day and age and I think that that
scares a lot of people that scares a lot
of people and I think that maybe that
they've done created a case against him
to maybe stop him from having that
influence as much I don't know people
was when was the first time you were
mentioned negatively in the media
wow like does do comment section count
or no
well no no no just just like mainstream
media newspaper kind of thing
I don't know I didn't even pay attention
to it maybe
I I probably when they did the like
female Andrew Tate article maybe how
many subscribers did you have
like between 500k to a million maybe
roughly but I was growing really fast I
like I've been getting 100 like 50 to
100 million views a month for like a
year and a half and that's just YouTube
not even tick tock
yeah I I don't have that much uh reach
or views but I have been portrayed
negatively in the media too it's really
easy to just get portrayed negatively
and falsely yeah Jesus Christ what did
they do not trust them what they say
about you oh my god well there were a
few but
um basically I had uh two years ago uh
there were some trolls who joined my
groups and I banned this particular
Troll and the these uh this fake
organization went to a journalist uh it
like to prove that it's not even a real
organization you can email them and they
won't even email back that they don't
even exist but it's like um some kind of
movement
and what what happened was some random
troll who was Asian I know that he's
Asian because I know who he was I banned
him for something he said he said
something about uh we should go back to
the caveman days where you could just
Bonk a woman on the head like yes that
is bad but I banned him for making that
comment and they uh said that he is one
of my members but no he was banned that
day and that happened a year before so
that's something they didn't tell you it
was just completely false yeah I think
they're making a documentary about me
soon it's called the rise of pearl Davis
so I guess oh wow but but the point is
so I don't think it's going to be
positive I don't I don't think it's
gonna be a good yeah the thing is like
it it's someone like me someone like you
or someone with any kind of reach it's
very easy to get haters negative
responses and then someone with like
Andrew Tate most Googled man on on Earth
it's inevitable that someone will make a
wild claim inevitable because those same
claims will not trafficking necessarily
but similar claims happen to random
people who aren't even on the internet
without it necessarily being true right
what type of content do you do
um so I interview people who I'm a
dating coach basically I wrote a
best-selling book about online dating
um and I interview people like roll
tomasi Michael 13 Brandon Carter
um Luke Crowe Vera sellers so I I talk
about
um dating a little bit of business but
lifestyle in general just self
self-improvement right for men right
obviously you've interviewed like
Sartain Rolo and all that yeah Russ
jaffrey's too if you're you know that
guy I don't know him but so he did a
crazy he went on NBC in 1992
31 years ago and it they they surprised
him so the producers
um surprised him with all female
audience
of 200 women and his frame control was
just so wild I I did
um an interview with him just over a
year ago where we talk about this 30
years after it happened if you see uh
like how he was reacting to to the
comments from the women in the audience
it's just completely insane really how
he held himself like so many people
would just crumble with pressure within
two seconds where are you from Nova
Scotia where's that
um so it's near Boston but it's not
American it's Canadian oh okay do you
guys are you live in London yeah so she
was like this is interesting Peru we're
stuck here basically because because of
her brain cancer is dangerous to fly so
uh she was diagnosed what while we were
in London so we were stuck here until
further notice wow so were you on
vacation uh so I I we've been working
I was moving around so I used to study
University in London and then because of
the pandemic my graduation was delayed
by two years so by by the time I
finished and was long gone we were back
in Peru
um
our second my second or third time there
and then I had to come back for
graduation because that was delayed by a
few years and I was like okay let's stay
a little bit longer and then she got
diagnosed with cancer
how did that like change your
relationship was it like um what was
that like so I'm gonna say we have had
more arguments since but the way that I
see it is there's nothing harder than
cancer like after we get through this
there's not a thing that can
ever stop us yeah
100 one thing I want to say I was
thinking about who tell you to do fans
Not fans only fans only yeah yeah so
your mom right I mean my mom didn't make
me do it but she said she said she was
happy for me to do it yeah yeah me it's
the family is your family who tell you
what to do and everything for example my
family always told me since I was a
child you have to study you have to
worry you have to study what do you want
to study a doctor a lawyer whatever no
so I I always say doctor but I I wasn't
too smart so a all my family started in
the university and then a a work no but
this is because a family in your case I
don't know how is your mom but your mom
is teaching you to be a person
who once you you are telling me no I
want a person who in a judge I I want to
drive my your car no yeah yeah yeah yeah
so is what you think because your mother
your family creates you like this
yeah I mean my mom my mom doesn't have
that lifestyle she's not like a a rich
wife but um I think their acceptance
definitely made it easier for me to do
it if that makes sense like obviously my
family are my closest unit so for them
to say to me we're happy for you to do
that as long as you respect us and you
know I don't really see how that is
respected in your family to a certain
degree no I mean like don't don't your
parents think more highly of you no
about to think like like you could do so
much better like I mean it's like if I
was to turn around to my mum and say oh
you know I'm gonna be a gigolo tomorrow
because I don't feel like I can do
anything better and like like all these
years that you've studied or been to
school or you know been around certain
peers that you don't think that there
would be a better like
way for you to make your money I
wouldn't I wouldn't even blame I
wouldn't blame I wouldn't blame her
family in per se neither would I blame
her mom I would blame the men so what
I've come to realize is Western Society
is filled with a lot of weak men and
there's this same Hard Times create
strong men strong men create good times
good times create weak men and then the
cycle goes on so basically what happened
in the West Was the West became this
really prosperous place and everybody
started Living Well and there was no
need for people to sacrifice or struggle
anymore the way most people in the world
do so what that then happened was that
those are in quotes quotes good times
that created with men and now we have a
generation of weak men who can't even
lead their homes who can't even tell
their daughters
that if you do this I will disown you if
you do this you're bringing shame to the
family that's literally the problem with
the Western World so then we have the
women that now come and run things and
then they they give this terrible advice
to their children and then it just keeps
going for example my husband her parents
never told him you have to study you
have to do this no if he goes he does
but her family never pushed him to study
so for I think people do YouTube
Instagram all those things because it's
the family that's in support to study is
what I think I don't know
I got a huge respect for my
father-in-law because uh he works hard
so so much time that he's working but
he's a family man
it's like for real I want you to come to
Peru with us you should see it because
this is Pearl world yeah you have to see
it you'll be like oh my God I gotta make
20 YouTube videos about Peru now really
yeah you're gonna look can you get me a
panel of checks Peruvian yeah yeah we
are going along on September the next
year if you want you can go with us yeah
if you can get me a panel of chicks I'll
come out I've been wanting to do this
like to go in different places
yeah uh oh Monty Picchu yeah oh okay
okay okay I wish I was supposed to do
that before covet I was supposed to like
it's like a hike isn't it it's a long
hike well not not necessarily so there's
like the Inca Trail which a lot of
Australians tend to do because
Australians are like that
um but we we just went to like the
nearby Village and then just visit the
place but we did go up the mountain
waiana Pichu which is the one you see in
all the photos
um Machu Picchu is actually actually
behind the photo that you're looking at
when when you Google it but uh that
nearly killed me uh she took me there on
my birthday it takes two hours to get up
we'll cut that bit it's like a big it's
like the stairs were made in the ancient
Inc at times so no health and safety and
if you fall you die I'm serious you have
to sign in before you go like uh just to
clarify if you go to Machu Picchu what
I'm talking about is an extra thing you
don't have to climb up that thing in the
background that that's just an extra
thing that I'm talking about that we did
but if you do only 200 or 400 people can
do it per day you have to sign in and I
had jelly legs all the way down because
I I ran out of food ran out of water I I
was so unprepared for it and it was hot
uh so my mind was trying to make me
survive because people died there I
nearly died there and if you follow
through the edge they may never find
your body it's that bad and it was so
bad for me that when I finally got to
the exit I didn't even think about
signing out they had to stop me and get
me to sign up and then less than five
minutes later I collapsed I lost all
feeling in my body and I could only move
my eyes it was that bad and they had to
pump me up with sugar to revive me after
a few hours
I'm adding it to my book at least
so I'm curious how did
something so serious kind of affect your
view on the world
um are you referring to Machu Picchu no
the cancer yeah so uh for one because I
I run such a huge network of men who are
in dating and self-improvement self-help
uh I get questions every single day uh
just a few hours ago before coming on
there was a guy who was like
can someone help me but he he just
doesn't write what the problem is like
at least write it if you want
help if you want help you need to
help yourself specify what you
need help with don't just expect us to
wipe your ass and do everything for you
so uh we are dealing with not only a
relationship but a family a child uh
with cancer too uh it's a lot of stuff
cancer is really hard to deal with and
it's not easy to get it to go away it is
really difficult so
just understand that
there will be hard times and for us we
are going through a hard time now and
the thing is I don't see dating coaches
go on podcasts with their girlfriends I
took my wife here she has cancer we're
coming here at our weakest at our lowest
what does that say no because when they
have a stubborn cancer I lost the memory
of English I can speak Spanish very well
but English I have to speak slow and
hear very well because sometimes but
every day I speak better why because the
doctor is the do the operation and then
I couldn't speak anything any
and then after a day a date the doctor
give me like a treatment and then I
could speak like like now
and every day I could speak better
better not yeah so the the brain surgery
which was right after Christmas I think
it was like eight hours long 12 hours
long something insane obviously I
couldn't be there because that would be
annoying for the doctors they have to
concentrate on something extremely
serious but I remember that day I I
think I was interviewing Raul tomazi and
then from that moment I was like I
really need to produce more videos take
things more seriously because I'm just
wasting time if I'm not doing
that so now my YouTube channel has been
growing a lot more because since doing
that video at that time that she had was
having brain surgery that's when I I
want to call it motivation motivation is
temporary but discipline that's when the
discipline came in that's when
the the it it really empowered me to
really take things seriously take my
time seriously and get things done and
also the doctor doesn't tell you you
have brain cancer no they tell you you
can die in two years because this is a
percentage of debts something like this
73 chance
you cannot see you can lose the hearing
you can not see in one night a lot of
things they tell you in the radio in the
chemo and all those things but happily I
as I believe in God I think thanks God I
am okay because I am working I am doing
everything normal and you see me okay
but maybe my English is not too good but
I try you know always try to get this
day to learn more take your life
seriously
no because I just think like when you go
through something so serious it's got to
make you look at life like a little
different
and like when people complain you guys
gotta I'd be yeah like for real shut the
up
where are you complaining
um let me I think there's a couple super
go ahead yeah like you do have problems
everyone has problems but uh when
something hits you like this it doesn't
invalidate your problems but you just
have to realize how how fortunate you
are in the position you're in you might
be broke solution make more money is it
that simple no but it's not harder than
beating cancer
so you better work on that for
the sake of us
we are your motivation your example
it's easier to make money than it is to
beat cancer you can do it if
you're broke whatever your problem is if
you think you can't get into a
relationship is that harder than cancer
it's not it's not enough I was saying
about like just
giving yourself a chance you know what
I'm saying because a lot of the time we
downbeat ourselves or talk ourselves
down like we like we're not capable
which is what I'm saying and for you to
be going through something as hard as
brain cancer and still be fighting it
and living just what I'm saying like
the things that like like you're talking
about relationships you're so minuscule
to that you see what I'm saying so like
I'm saying you have to give yourself
time out here you have to know yourself
as a person as well just what I'm saying
we all have qualities that people can
endear to but it's what you want to show
people just say what I'm saying so if
you're not showing them the things in
the right light then you can't expect to
get out of Darkness just say I'm saying
and that's how I see things really
intriguing but I commend you for like
you know just staying strong because a
lot of people once they're getting
diagnosed with things like cancer go
into a show and crumble and don't feel
like they can come out into society and
even talk about it you know what I mean
so yeah I commend you for that one yeah
I'm curious as a dating coach like what
what are the biggest mistakes that you
see men make and why
and do you think there's a percentage of
men that have like no chance
um I don't really
want to go into like the no chance being
because I I I'm not the I know there are
some people out there who have some kind
of condition they have Tourette's or
even worse things I'm just thinking of a
person I have in mind who spent one or
two years harassing me on a daily basis
making new phone numbers so a guy like
that okay good good luck I can't help
you
um and I don't think you can help
yourself not many people can help you
that that's an extreme though if you
think that you have no chance and you
have legs you have arms you have a brain
right without holes in it and a fully
formed skull that doesn't have metal
plates
um oh I'm ugly or I can't talk to women
these are things that can be improved
improve the things that you can improve
right right because there's no there's
no point like you can't really like
that's all you can do is get better yeah
I I think like if if we're talking about
like biggest mistakes
biggest mistakes are that people don't
really have their own willpower or
confidence more to be more specifically
uh more specific what I specialize in is
messaging so online dating messages or
stuff like that okay that's what my book
was about which became a bestseller uh
it was extremely practical so when it
comes to the messaging aspect one of the
most common mistakes is that people
think well not just men but women too
that messaging is for getting to know
each other it's not you need to meet
also a man needs to lead the
conversation if she opens uh your uh
Tinder if she matches you with you on
Tinder she opens uh the conversation and
she tells you hey how are you and you
say oh I'm good thanks what about you
you need to lead the
conversation stop letting her lead it uh
studies show that this question no
matter if it's online dating or in
person I hate this question how are you
how basic is this so boring
there are so there are more than a
million words in the English language
and you're choosing the most basic
sentence that society says and nobody
actually asks it in a genuine way so it
is that's not a good story you need to
lead the conversation with purpose and
that purpose is to meet
so what's your what's can we do like a
messaging like like a pretend like like
what you would say so what would you be
your opener uh so my maybe my most
famous one or one of them at least is
let's skip all the how
adventurous are you
oh
okay and so then I'll be like well I
rollerblade so let's do it what's your
phone number
there are examples where I have got the
phone number in two or three messages I
have that on my website that was so good
I'm so impressed actually it's as easy
as that yeah okay whereas other people
are like uh yeah now do you like
dolphins
yeah what the are you talking about
you're remember my my opener was let's
skip all the I'm skipping the
if you're talking about
dolphins not Dolphins but
Dolphins if you're talking about these
random things
it where's the direction the direction
needs to be that you end up meeting each
other so you need the date idea she gave
me one rollerblading I got it I don't
even need to work
harder than that
wow that was good um okay I'm gonna read
that that's a clip
no I was just thinking I'm like because
it's good too because then the girl says
What She Likes doing so it's like easier
too so here's here's a crazier one so
one of my this isn't necessarily an
opener and I never I really used it as
an opener but it was very good uh it's
called the free things link so what are
free things you would love to do for
first date and it comes in many
variations so at the end you could also
say no matter how crazy so could you
answer that three things I'd like to do
on a first date no matter how crazy no
matter how crazy okay this is gonna be
very specific to me
um basketball rollerblading
um and I like sushi okay I like those
things I'm tall you're tall basketball
would be good for me uh Sushi I Love
Sushi but I never tried it until a few
years ago so just if you haven't tried
it give it a try and the the was there a
roller okay I have a bad history with
ice skating because I nearly had a freak
accident where I nearly less fingers but
I would give that a go uh so you just
asked the girl that and then yeah some
sometimes you might get some crazy
answers like skydiving okay I don't
think most people want to go skydiving
it's not practical how far away is that
like we're in the middle of the city so
uh that's less practical so in which
case you still got two other options
that you gave if she complied with The
Specific Instructions of providing free
and if none of those free suggestions
work for you coming back to my point
about leading you can suggest an
alternate alternative right which works
for you huh
okay Emmanuel said I see what you're
saying
um let me see if there's any other
supers I'm gonna read
guys can you like the video please you
guys are being such like you're being so
lame today it's like 540 likes we've got
over a thousand people in here it's like
come on a like is free okay uh C
matherson said I should become an AI
girl oh yeah what do you think of AI
he's doing it yeah
me or these guys now what if AI takes
your job I actually said before we
started the Pod I actually said about
that because only fans girls are at risk
with AI coming in like there there's
there's this whole talk about they're
creating models with AI they're creating
chats with AI like I don't know like I
think they said you can wait 10 years
and have the perfect AI version wife or
you can have it only fans girl right now
which would you choose
yeah but I don't know maybe with I AI
you might not get as a personal
experiences yeah
you you
I mean it would be more intense and I
think maybe you could
fulfill their fantasies in a more
realistic way if that makes any sense
um but I do think that it is a scary
concept that AI will probably take over
the industry I'm not gonna lie but hey
hey we woke up until then it's not only
okay well we should end the show on it's
not only over for single mothers it's
also over for only fans models yeah
unfortunately yeah good luck um okay
guys um why don't we end the show and do
any final thoughts I'm I'm so impressed
with that I was such a good opener that
was so good
do you do anything so
um give any final thoughts you want to
tell people where to find you I'm
starting here and then go around okay
um so yeah um you can find me but not
her no yes no don't don't subscribe
Please Subscribe don't subscribe guys
honestly you will not be disappointed
and you can find me on Instagram uh hire
him instead
you don't want to date you just wanna no
no no no
he'll help you with it no I'm you can
find me on Instagram at Daisy Mae
Barrett or on um obviously any fans at
the little princess and also on Twitter
and Tick Tock at Daisy Mayberry but yeah
it's been nice talking to you guys so
thanks
uh I have my Instagram you can find me
as a La chinita power and it's about
brain cancer what you can stay your diet
keto diet exercise
um everything about brain cancer if you
don't don't know what to do
Aya if the eye can teach you because the
doctor doesn't tell you anything the
nurse nothing they only said that you
have to eat at everybody but I don't eat
any sugar and a lot of things so if you
want to find me is on Instagram and it's
La chinita power
just to clarify my wife this heals her
size so are you able to show lift your
leg up a little bit she she wears 80
inch high heels to to exercise in which
is pretty crazy and that's done because
she has cancer so it's a challenge so
that that's pretty interesting but uh
for for me you can find me on Instagram
Ice white official Facebook ice white
personal telegram uh which is where a
lot of my network is my group's ice
white official if you want to find my
book I actually got a copy here to give
to you as a gift oh
it is oh God what's happening with my
ears uh it is called the message game
bestseller in online dating it is
extremely practical so there are
screenshots in there uh I'm working on
these nuts
so I'm working on the second edition
right now
um this was released a few years ago and
and we have new things such as only fans
so option A subscribe to her only fans
option b read this book and if
that's not crazy enough we have also
turned this book into AI so it's called
mgei after message game the message game
um I was thinking about calling it a ice
weight but then it's too close to what
my name is so they'll be confusing uh
because my name begins with I but it is
the AI wingman for online dating so you
can send what your situation is she sent
me this and then mgei will give you
exactly what to respond with so you can
find that uh just find one of my
profiles my oh yeah there's also my
YouTube channel game Global uh you can
find videos there with Ross Jeffries or
ultimasi Michael Sartain you did a great
episode with him by the way and soon I
hope I can help you too oh yeah we also
have the AI online dating podcast on uh
on that channel too okay cool
yeah cool
um my name is dng dirty cash dng dirty
with the e no I cash
um you can catch that on Instagram
um as well as that I've got a YouTube
channel I'm like one of the best rappers
now in the UK so you can check out my
music online dng dirty Cash music on
YouTube
um yeah check that out as well and
that's about it also I've got a film
coming out hopefully I'm gonna start
filming it next year
um we've got the clothing line mvs side
no vision seems impossible you can check
out my website which is
www.nvsa third eye apparel.com and we
sell women's and men's bespoke jewelry
on there as well as clothing so yeah
let's check it out man it's got some fly
hot coming for you guys and so
let's check it out
and also one last thing I just want to
say
learn to trade learn to trade yeah
that's it man because the women aren't
gonna do it I promise
now now guys
couple things first of all
none of these problems she wouldn't be
on only fans if they didn't give us the
right to vote to begin with you know all
the world's problems started when they
started giving women all these choices
so look
I know obviously I'm going to vote for
the good guys but I'll take one for the
team and I'll women shouldn't vote so
buy your women shouldn't vote t-shirts
at the audacity Network dot store the
link to that is in the description also
guys uh make sure you subscribe to the
channel and like the video on your way
out
and sign up for a one-on-one with me
once a month if you want to know how to
grow on YouTube like the video I'll talk
to you next time
thanks guys
oh